this week the senate is expected to
confirm the first black woman to serve
on the supreme court the judiciary
committee meets this morning for a vote
to send judge katanji brown jackson's
nomination to the senate floor now if
she is confirmed it's likely to be with
almost no republican support nicole
killian is covering brown's confirmation
process nicole good morning to you so
what do we expect this morning's vote
how do we expect it to go
well gale judge katanji brown jackson
appears to have enough support to get
confirmed to the supreme court by the
senate by the end of this week but her
first hurdle will be getting out of the
senate judiciary committee which is
expected to vote today on party lines
some republicans on the panel who tried
to press the judge during her
confirmation hearings have already said
they'll oppose her citing her judicial
philosophy and some of her sentencing
decisions if the committee splits in a
tie democrats can still advance her
nomination and are planning a floor vote
later this week jackson is expected to
have the backing of democrats and at
least one republican maine senator susan
collins which would allow her to be
confirmed with at least some bipartisan
support a senior white house adviser
tells me that they still believe there
are some undecided gop lawmakers out
there that they hope to get which is why
judge jackson will be back on the hill
this week meeting with more senators
ahead of the final vote nate
we shall see nicole thank you